[Music]
I'm doing excellent listen I want to
start by saying how much I loved this
movie and you both of your work in it
it's such an incredible and important
story can you sort of talk about the
fact that stories like this they're
really hard to get made you know like we
all love superhero movies and the big
explosions and stuff but this is like a
real important film it's a yes I think
typically 1,000% you know one thing
about this project you know you this one
wasn't that hard and I think because we
had all the right elements involved I
think we had you know the material in
Brian Stevenson who is a very important
person who was incredible man and the
work that he's doing is second to none
and having you know a director in Destin
who saw the vision who cared as much as
Brian that this thing was done the right
type of way a studio who fully supported
it you know other producers gillnetter
Asher you know a lot of you know myself
the production company who wasn't in a
rush to making it they wanted to make it
for all the right reasons you know then
finding a cast that equally cared as
much about the story in the process I
think we really found all the right
pieces and at the right time it was a
weird how some things just kind of come
together and this movie was definitely
one of them so it wasn't that hard to
get made I mean looking from the outside
you put a lot of work into it and he put
the work in when he did Fruitvale
station I talk about this all the time
his DNA allows him to tell these types
of stories which is great for us because
these are stories that are so important
that you can't put a price tag on having
my father sit in the sit in the audience
who had been put in jail for $25 worth
of illegal substance for seven years
when he was an educator for 25 years
in the hood watching his face feeling
his emotion of what he's what this young
man put together it goes beyond and it
will continue bearing fruit this movie
will continue to bear fruit for it for
its existence so like like I said you
know and all my enemies I applaud
Michael B Jordan to take time out to do
a film like this because it means so
much to everybody I think that what
Brian has done is unbelievable and I
love that this film will shine a light
on his organization and help hopefully
others deal with the injustice in the
criminal justice system can you sort of
talk about that how art can something
like this can really inspire so many
people yeah I feel like you know our you
know music you know you know it's one of
those you know very powerful you know
storytelling purposes you know they it
makes people feel it makes people think
it gives them takes people on a ride of
emotions you know and I feel like you
know with with this movie we hopefully
people want to talk about it you know I
want to go home and look at themselves
in the mirror and ask themself questions
you know where they were part of a part
of history they want to stand on you
know and and I think you know it also
helps people feel like they can be part
of the solution you know that they don't
have to be paralyzed you know I think
some issues seem so big it's like well
what can I do to actually you know you
know help this or stop this huge
injustice that's going on it's like no
you could be a part of it you could you
can be compassionate you can be you know
motivated to find your thing and be
passionate about it and then actually go
out there and try to do something folk
you know you can educate it on certain
situations how can you actually apply
yourself and start making a difference
in every person counts you know vote and
get out and vote the simplest you get
your the right that you have get out
there involved and hopefully that'll
start making a difference